you know up on that stage when I was up
there it was it's terrifying but for you
guys it must be just such a rush into
feel your fans and to see them
it is exciting it's like you get many
hunt or something like for us
yeah not a fear thing it's that great
raring to go
have you seen the YouTube video raised
last jump no you go see it okay I watch
it it's some amazing Canadian culture
okay ahead of time your watch okay we
know what your fans get out of your
music but for you what do you get back
from them they say it's a religious
experience seeing seeing you guys and
being with you we have a job because of
them and we get to do what we love to do
and create and try to figure out how to
every year to bring a different show to
them in a different way
so it gives us a lot of purpose and it
gives us our well-being as well so I
mean in the connection we have with them
on stage it creates that like the
turbine of energy that vortex that we
get then and the more that they give to
us the more that we can get back to them
you know so I like shows when there's a
lot of people standing down front
you know smiles when they sell seats and
then seats are all down front everybody
has to be kind of stiff it's not quite
as good when they're right up in the
face kind of
screaming so so then you guys prefer the
the the recording of the music or
getting out on the road and performing
the music definitely performing but
they're both cool I mean getting in the
studio is great too because you get to
be intricate with the music you get to
make the best sounds possible and you
get no sound interference you get good
mics and but stage there's nothing like
having thousands of people cheering back
at you and smiling and just thinking
like while we're kind of doing this
that's right and I mean even this last
album was so well received do you expect
that to happen or is every time this
this kind of happens and you get
received this way are you just just
happy that it's happened yeah I think
you're just happy that it's happened
mm-hmm and we always want to kind of
push the because we're curious like what
what we're capable of doing and so we
don't ever want to abandon any of the
things that people have discovered us
you know and know us for but we are
excited to push kind of beyond the
boundaries of what people would expect
as well so I want to abandon anything
but want to gain gain some things so
that's a lot of fun
I'm really glad that the album as well
received because then we get to make
another one that's right which means
then you're out on the road how do you
guys handle being away from your
families I mean you all have obligations
at home to house that we get home every
week do ya just to keep to keep
everybody it makes no sense at all as
far as the logistics wise but we do it
because that's more important than we
have to have a balance of both be gone
and stay up all night and play music and
you gotta be home and
and be the dads and family family folks
you got some new ones on the way yeah
okay we're cuz I see nodding over here
both of them.last really the Bulls IOC
Mexico I don't I don't want to gets
personal but it was it happen in Mexico
we did a gig down in Mexico and we both
came back from that and we're having
kids now that's amazing
this is very very important now if any
of your family members wanted to get
into this business would you guys be
okay with that knowing everything that
you know now there's nobody gonna tell
me that I couldn't do it so you're just
gonna have to sit back and wait and see
hopefully you train them to be as solid
of people as they can
yeah somebody told me once Alma if you
teach your children to be good people
then they'll be successful at whatever
that they decide to do so okay that's
the weekend hopefully we have enough
time I'm gonna do that what's the key to
enjoying a good festival everybody's got
these things you know hydrate wear
proper shoes like these this is not the
best idea I'm basically aerating the
lawn so what's the what are some keys to
enjoying a good music festival less rain
is a moonshine or that that's a that's
it and for you I just pace yourself just
pace yourself I see a lot of people have
passed out and drunk before we even hit
the stage the faces if you could find a
good seat you know somewhere we can take
the take it take the lady toes your ass
a little bit
take the heat off of it and just kind of
rest for a second then get back at it
because what kills me you just standing
up all day you know absolutely no proper
footwear it does so there it is
so what do you think it separates your
Canadian fans from your fans all around
the world or a border a border I like
that your guys are quick quick and witty
what is there is there a difference is
there a different appreciation for the
music at all
they know a lot of the verses to the
song so a lot of them do they'll be
singing the whole time I've noticed they
don't know a lot of songs that are crazy
popular down in the south where we're
from so we tried some covers that we
know are gonna do it and not one person
song so it kind of changes our setlist a
little bit yeah people get down here
people you know bathing suits and all
whatever they just come out get down
nice well have a great time tonight
thanks for taking the time we appreciate
it